set the world on fire he's on minus one  favi at fifty percent  this is very hard to say i don't think  any gets enough credit for how good he  is  in a proper bar fight and rugby  probably i would take  this is probably a misclick yeah oops  martian lobby  just as i said  but yeah i would have spotted that  yeah that was probably spottable yeah  but sometimes i just miss the right  moment like i write up a lengthy reply  then i wonder oh did i phrase this  correctly will he take this wrong way  and then i just don't don't dare sending  it then i feel i missed the moment it's  too late and i don't answer at all  that's i i i know you you've got a  million things but i um  yeah it's cool we're all good actually  uh magnus has uh has ghosted me probably  just as long to think about it he's  he's he's been a bit absent which is  which is nice  so what this is the only game we got and  then we got uh  itself  it just so we're done so